pour ce faire ce sont des moments qui
tous les masques entendront quoi
il a dit la barbarie de grandir
tout écouté
c'est ce que tu veux
je ne sais pas
il y a un beau site
mais je ne connais pas la couleur de la robe
le français le français
et ce n'est jamais en papier
C'est comme ça que je les envoie et les envoie si pour moi
la ching
J'ai dit allons-y
un jeune homme blanc a poussé
Ouais
c'est très bien que nous y soyons allés
dans une autre école
personne ne voit le visage
Netflix
[Musique]
les choses vont devenir très
et rester au régime
la précédente
[Musique]
En 2011, la Banque centrale européenne
mais du ghana 171 milliards d'euros
de nulle part
tout comme nous le faisons
[Musique]
mais pas
c'est un moment
écoutez moi tout le monde c'est une opération
très complexe donc nous allons avoir besoin
concentration extrême cette fois
nous avons le piège
[Musique]
l'enseignant est détenu dans un
situation critique
et puis tout cela finira
[Musique]
Ouais
et c'est comme ça que tout a commencé
tout ça serait la fin du casse